Baby birds sometimes fall from their nests,...
...and sometimes are knocked out by storms or other natural causes.
If you find a baby bird, here's how to feed it.
You will need: a container, a heating pad, dog kibble, hot sugar water,...
...a bowl, a spoon, hard-boiled eggs, baby cereal, toothpicks, canned cat or dog food, lean raw beef and fruit.
Step 1 : Place the baby bird in a container on top of a heating pad to keep it warm.
Handle the bird only when necessary.
Step 2 : Prepare the food by soaking dog kibble in hot sugar water for one hour.
Step 3 : Remove the kibble from the water and mix it with baby cereal and a hard-boiled egg.
Feed the baby bird with this mixture for the first couple of days.
Step 4 : Make a pea - size ball with the food mixture and place it in the baby's mouth using a toothpick.
Never force food or water into the bird's mouth.
Step 5 : Feed the bird every 15 minutes over the first couple of days.
When it's stronger, feed it every 30 to 60 minutes.
Step 6 : Feed the baby bird room temperature canned dog food, lean raw beef and fruit after the first couple of days.
Step 7 : Wean it away from hand - feeding once it starts moving around.
Did you know? In 2007, an ostrich egg set a record for the largest egg from a living bird at five pounds nine ounces.